[Music]
it's time to get christmassy oh
are you ready i'm ready okay so we
decided i mean look
look at this yeah look at that look at
this look at you
look at this it's christmas okay we
decided to make a big deal of christmas
this year because
the pandemic showed us that you can't
put things off until later you got to
make a big deal of stuff
now even though it sucks a butt now we
may not have our families this year but
we do have a tarik
and a me and a you and that's gonna make
for a fun
christmas okay so during this magical
episode
we're all gonna amber
we're all gonna amber
what is that who's there it is i
the ghost of jacob marley in life i
never thought much beyond money
and now in death i bear the chains of a
man who has squandered his life away
amber mildred ruffin
tonight you will be visited by three
ghosts
i will what what
don't you bring any ghosts around here i
swear to god i will
beat the [ __ ] out of a ghost i dare you
you ain't your little friends
well i just wanted to warn you here's
your warning
do you want to die a second time trying
to harm me
[ __ ] terry do you see this mess yeah
how you running around threatening
people when you ain't even alive
with your dusty ass look just cause you
dead don't mean you can't get your ass
whooped
can't wait to go stop say something say
something say something say something
this is not how i imagine this going
yeah you better run tis the season of
a ghost anyway we have a really fun show
tonight
we're going to have songs and sketches
and more songs but
before we move on to our next segment i
want to tell everybody
wait a minute what's that oh my god oh
my god is that
santa you're here that's right amber
and you know my name well of course i do
in fact umber you've been at the top of
my good list for quite some time
and because you've been so good i wanted
to stop by and let you personally give
me your christmas wish this year
it can be absolutely anything in the
world you just name it
now i know you will have to take some
time to think about it so don't worry if
you take a little too long a 12 ounce
bottle of the discontinued sea island
cotton lotion from bath and body works
what bath and body works discontinued
one of my favorite fragrances this year
and
i can't find it anywhere it's very
annoying and i don't want to find a new
fragrance so that's what i want for
christmas
amber you know you can wish for
literally anything right i mean
if you want a playstation 5 yes give me
the lotion
what about some nice jewelry maybe not
interested lotion please
i can get you the vaccine oh so i can
finally leave my house and have everyone
coming at me like
whoa amber you smell different covett
put a decidedly
non-fruitful non-floral stank on you
absolutely not
i want that damn lotion santa okay
what's going on is this an ad
are you being paid by bath and body
works oh no no no
if this were an ad i would not be able
to say that i literally
do not give a [ __ ] about any of the
other fragrances in that store
not one of them the whole lot is trash
and is too expensive but
if i were getting paid to say this i
would be asking them to pay me in
bottles of their discontinued
sea island cotton fragrance i was really
expecting you to ask for something like
world peace or an end of all war
something that would be good for you and
for other people you know
wow okay well when you put it like that
i
i guess i wasn't really thinking about
other people it's been such a rocky year
for everybody and
here you are giving me a chance to make
that right the fact that i could think
only of myself well
it's a wonder i ever got on the good
list at all
maybe i'm the wrong person to have such
a privilege if this is how i'm going to
use it
i mean how many people truly get to ask
santa himself for
all of their christmas wishes well no
it's just
the one wish oh just one yeah
yeah okay the make with the lotion santa
i mean
i think i'm gonna have to find it on
ebay or something but yeah i'll get you
the lotion
hell yeah you guys getting presents
is definitely one of the best christmas
traditions but
it's not my favorite my favorite
christmas tradition is elf on the shelf
okay elf on the shelf is where santa
sends an elf to your house
to keep track of whether or not you've
been good this year
it's so cute those things are creepy man
i
tara don't say that it's just a fun
little doll i guess
but there's just something off about
them you know
no have you ever taken a good long look
in their eyes
i guess not well i have and
i swear something was just staring right
back at me i don't know
every time i think about them i gotta go
reach for my inhaler
derek you're crazy i think they are fun
and that's why we got one for the studio
[Music]
you got what an elf on the shelf
yay we love you anyways
my favorite christmas songs are the ones
that are just a big long list of
christmasy stuff
so i wrote one on my own it's called
big old list of christmasy stuff hit it
big old dangly jiggly bales cinnamon
pine cone christmasy smells
mistletoe and a warm pajamas with a flap
on your butt
for pooping eggnog turkey
jellies and dams santa claus and
christmas hail
real snow fake snow it's a big old list
of christmasy stuff
men and gingerbread girls marshmallow
pogo candy cream squirrels
holiday cars and snowflakes and for some
reason
peanut brittles advent calendars
mistletoe
rudolph's big red shiny nose red gum
drops
free plum drops into big old lipstick
and stuff popcorn on
a string wrapped around a pine tree
that you cut down so it could die
inside your house
oh no miss and family fights
ebony's retired tim flickering lights
glitter gets
all over your house and no one knows how
that happens
snow globes presents gingerbread house
not a creature
not even a mouse holly
[Music]
[Music]
where's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you